sur mitterrand nous sommes ensemble pour
la bande à moi je crois qu'on aura pas
trop de temps parce que j'ai beaucoup de
questions à vous poser des questions
très précises et très ponctuel je crois
trois jours du scrutin s'impose tous les
français ont vu monsieur giscard
d'estaing hier soir donner des
indications sur votre programme qui sont
de nature peut-être à les inquiéter
je crois que l'actualité commande qu'on
les prenne dans l'ordre depuis que vous
me disiez ce qui c'est vrai est
et qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à
ça alors je commençais pas la première
y'aura t'il oui ou non une taxation des
plus values sur la résidence principale
des français si vous êtes blanc pouvoir
non mensonge
il n'y aura pas de taxation sur le
logement la loi sur les plus values
étaient proposées par monsieur giscard
d'estaing est voté par ses amis pas par
les miens il n'y aura pas je le répète
de taxation sur le logement
bien entendu je taxerait les très
grandes fortunes qui s'investissent dans
la spéculation foncière dans la
détention d'objets de luxe eux ou bien
sûr les diamants celui pas du tout la
même chose
la maison l'appartement l'oeuf avions
non je viens de le dire par les droits
de succession maintenant important aussi
ils sont à l'heure actuelle de 20%
est ce que oui ou non vous proposer de
les porter à 45 % à partir de 500 mille
francs d'héritage en ligne directe à
dire par enfants marie fable mensonge je
maintiendrai et je les dix les 20 % et
même j'ai prévu d'accroitre
l'exonération sur les successions en
ligne directe en faisant passer la base
de cette exonération de 175 mille francs
à 400 milles sans bien entendu encore
une fois les grandes fortunes
au delà de 3 millions de francs actuels
et compte non tenu de l'instrument de
travail en particulier le sol pour les
agriculteurs seront taxés davantage
autre argument employé dans le débat est
souvent la nationalisation de la moitié
de notre industrie
c'est là aussi c'est vrai ou c'est faux
nous en avons discuté mais très
brièvement avant-hier soir j'ai déjà
mise au point hier soir voyez que cette
affaire revient comme un serpent de mer
en vérité les chiffres de
lui pourcentage de monsieur giscard
d'estaing sont fantaisistes et imprécis
dans l'état actuel des choses le secteur
nationalisé qui a été nationalisé
surtout par le général de gaulle je le
répète en 1945 ça représente le gaz
électricité charbonnages les banques
toutes les banques de dépôt les
assurances renault que sais-je encore
cela représente 12 % de notre production
les mesures qui doivent viser le reste
des banques les banques d'affaires par
les banques mutuelles d' qui atteindront
11 groupes industriels pas davantage et
la liste est limitative
cela représentera en fin de compte 17 %
de notre production voilà la vérité
c'est donc un mensonge 17 ans mardi ce
qui a été dit hier soir par monsieur
giscard d'estaing il 7% donc pas 50% et
le rêve quoi les boutiques les commerces
quand on parle de l'économie de la
nation de l'économie on craint mais ses
boutiques et ses commerces elles ne sont
menacés que par la politique de monsieur
giscard d'estaing dans la mesure où il
est ce précisément les onze monopole ou
grandes sociétés ayant tendance au
monopole qui contrôle tout le marché
dans des secteurs clés de notre économie
ce sont ces grands groupes là que
j'entends nationaliser les onze dont
j'ai parlé et qui écrase les petites et
moyennes entreprises les petites et
moyennes industries qui devient des sous
traitants avant de devenir des salariés
peut être bien les chômeurs voilà la
vérité une question importante parce
qu'elle touche ce que les français au
plus profond là aussi l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
alors il paraît que vous voulez la
libéralisation totale de la loi sur
bg et que même les mineurs n'ont plus
besoin d'autorisation beaucoup car je
tiens à dire c'est que monsieur giscard
d'estaing a en effet proposé au
parlement la loi sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et cette loi n'a
pu être voté que par les suffrages de la
gauche
c'est un grave problème en effet qui se
posent ce que je demande c'est que
l'application de la loi soit égale pour
toutes les femmes et que n'en soient pas
victimes aujourd'hui comme c'est le cas
les femmes de condition modeste
donc ce que l'on appelle une libération
totale cela n'a pas de sens et liminaire
pour les mineurs nous devons considérer
que lorsqu'une mineurs se trouvent dans
le cas d'être en situation de grossesse
et doit pouvoir agir librement mais bien
entendu cette liberté-là devoir passer
par un contact avec les parents alors la
médecine et la pharmacie maintenant
secteur voisin je lis cette phrase un
service communautaire de santé avec un
rôle pilote confié au centre de soins
agréés
est-ce que c'est oui ou non un extrait
de votre programme mensonges mensonges
supplémentaires encore un mensonge et
nous n'en sommes qu'au 5e je pense
la liste sera plus longue il n'est pas
question de nationaliser la médecine ni
les pharmacies c'est clair et lorsqu'on
parle de centres de santé qu'est ce que
cela veut dire il faudrait quand même
prendre la peine de lire vos textes mes
textes et mes propositions avant de les
critiquer et de porter ce débat devant
l'opinion publique a expliqué là parce
qu'on vend ses centres de santé ça doit
simplement permettre surtout dans des
banlieues de grandes villes là où il ya
vraiment beaucoup de monde
souvent de la peine à pouvoir à réunir
tous les éléments pour garantir sa santé
cela doit permettre aux médecins qui le
veulent
volontaire de pouvoir réunir leurs
compétences et leurs activités souvent
dispersés ce sont des médecins de
médecine libérale qui font s'ils veulent
acte d'associations pour gérer un centre
de secours et nous pensons nous et moi
je pense que les malades peuvent trouver
là des soins complets tandis que les
médecins gardent leur entière liberté
qu'est ce qu'on peut interdire aux
médecins dans le cadre de la médecine
libérale
de se réunir pour essayer de soigner
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
mensonge supplémentaire que
l'affirmation de monsieur giscard
d'estaing votre programme et son
chiffrage je m'attends monsieur giscard
d'estaing dit que le mystère du budget
aux rites et sérieuse chiffres les
dépenses à 300 milliards de francs soit
le dixième des revues nationales
c'est vrai ça c'est faux mensonge pure
invention ayant les chiffres de monsieur
papon ministre du budget ont toujours
été d'une fantaisie suspecte il faudrait
s'y intéresser un peu doit peu plus près
à ce qui est proposé l'opinion publique
par ce curieux ministre ce chiffre de
300 milliards il faut il est totalement
faux
j'ai d'ailleurs dit que si l'on voulait
entrer dans ces détails mais vous savez
c'est une dispute sans fin que mon
programme ne coûtera jamais aussi cher
que ce qu'a coûté monsieur giscard
d'estaing pendant son septennat
simplement par le poids et le prix du
fromage 450 milliards en sept ans et
rien que cette année 135 milliards que
coûte à la nation le chômage que n'a pas
su guérir monsieur giscard d'estaing je
répèterai comme je l'aï dit avant-hier
soir que mon programme ne comptera
jamais aussi cher que ce que a coûté à
la france et aux français
le vol de l'héparine populaire qui avec
une inflation en s'étant multipliés 100
% représente une perte considérable pour
les petites gens pour des moyennes gens
qui n'ont pas le moyen de spéculer votre
programme toujours l'argument est le
suivant si vous êtes allé votre
programme votre déficit budgétaire sera
de 100 milliards en 82 et le déficit
extérieur aussi mensonge
il faudrait d'abord rappelé que le
déficit extérieur commercial représente
déjà actuellement pour l'année dernière
soit 100 milliards de francs c'est à
dire que si la politique de monsieur
giscard d'estaing devrait continuer
c'est lui qui arriverait à ces 100
milliards je ne vois pas pourquoi il les
attribue tout cela c'est de la
supputation sur l'avenir
compte non tenu de ma politique bien
entendu si je devais exercer joly dit
également
avant-hier ma politique dans le cadre de
celle de monsieur fiscale et ça je ne
pourrai rien faire ce que je veux dire
c'est que moi ma politique celle de la
croissance et du développement
et que j'entends reconquérir notre
marché intérieur c'est à dire offrir de
nouveaux marchés à nos entreprises à
partir du moment où sera pas obligé de
tout acheter à l'étranger avec des
entreprises qui à l'heure actuelle ou
des industries ne fonctionne qu'à
soixante dix pour cent de leur capacité
bien entendu je serais moi en mesure de
réduire nos déficits extérieurs ce n'est
pas le cas de monsieur giscard d'estaing
une question très concrète qui touche la
vie des gens de très près vous proposer
une augmentation des allocations
familiales donc une augmentation des
cotisations monsieur giscard d'estaing
10,2 points et demi de plus prélevés sur
les salaires
mensonges et nous en sommes qu en
huitièmes moi je le fais je le fais
parce que je dois informer les français
qui sont à l'heure actuelle l'objet
d'une un indigne campagne d'intoxication
celle de la peur mensonge supplémentaire
je dirais que j'ai en effet prévu
l'augmentation des allocations
familiales quoi il ne faudrait pas le
faire 25% tout de suite dès le mois de
mai prochain et 25% au début de 1982 les
allocations familiales n'ont pas suivi
le train des augmentations de salaire et
on sait de quelle façon les salaires ont
souvent été bloqués ou en retenue vous
apportez les cotisations non monsieur
giscard d'estaing il vit lui dans le
monde du chômage et ils résonnent
toujours par rapport au chômage c'est sa
spécialité
moi je vide dans la perspective d'une
politique de croissance et ce ne seront
pas les cotisations augmentent et qui
paieront cette augmentation des
allocations familiales
ce sera d'abord la croissance qui doit
produire simplement avec trois points 90
milliard 90 milliards d'autres au moins
190 500 milliards dont au moins 40 à 45
seront à la disposition des pouvoirs
publics est également la réduction du
chômage
j'ai dit tout à l'heure 135 milliards
que nous coûte le chômage pour cette
année présente si l'on réduit le nombre
de chômeurs bien entendu on trouve des
disponibilités nouvel an l'emploi des
jeunes a été un des thèmes de la
campagne
six cent mille jeunes vont arriveront
après l'été ça a marché du travail et
ont dit qu'il y aura pas d'emplois pour
eux qu'est ce que vous aurez
complètement désorganisé l'économie
c'est quand même embêtant mensonge
comment voulez-vous que j'interprète sur
ce que déclare monsieur giscard
d'estaing qui cherche un candidat qui se
sont battus a dit
tout et n'importe quoi pour tromper
l'opinion publique en vérité le plan que
j'ai développé pendant ma campagne
présidentielle suppose que je serai en
mesure de faire recruter sur pau soit
sur le plan public soit sur le plan
privé pas millions on attendait un
million de jeunes dans l'année qui vient
cela est un chiffre raisonnable parce
que à tout moment ce offre des capacités
dans beauf mais pour cela il faudra que
j'aide et j'aiderai les pme et des pmi
de telle sorte qu'ils soient en mesure
d'embaucher une belle façon par la
relance économique dont j'ai déjà parlé
par la réduction des charges sociales
n'est pas normal que les entreprises de
main d'oeuvre soit écrasée de telle
sorte qu'elles hésitent à recruter parce
qu'aussitôt leurs charges sociales
devient insupportable et puis aussi par
la modification de la taxe
professionnelle
il faut tout de même pas oublier
l'essentiel c'est que cette taxe
professionnelle elle a été imposée par
monsieur giscard d'estaing alors il veut
vraiment très aisé à trois jours d'un
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles de dire qu'il n'y est
pour rien ou qu'ils veulent a changé moi
je la changerait parce que je n'ai pas
de responsabilité dans cette mauvaise
loi quand je continue mon questionnaire
et les questions je voulais vous poser
voulez vous oui ou non la suppression du
régime autonome de la retraite des
cadres qui ont raté plafonnement des
cotisations mensonge encore il n'ya pas
dans mon programme de déplafonnement
pour les cotisations des cadres
notamment de cotisations vieillesse
c'est clair j'ai même écrit un livre
publié un livre il n'ya pas si longtemps
dans lesquelles j'ai écrit précisément
quelques phrases sur ce sujet en
indiquant que je n'entendais pas
m'attaquer en quoi que ce soit à la
retraite des cadres à la retraite
d'ailleurs de personnes c'est le fruit
du travail et 6 et celui ci ou celle là
entend développer par des moyens
complémentaires avoir quelque chose de
plus c'est son affaire et je n'entends
pas que monsieur giscard d'estaing
trompe les cadres qui ont d'ailleurs
bien à se plaindre de lui car en 1974 il
avait aussi promis beaucoup de choses
aux 4 qui n'ont pas été tenues
j'ajouterai le pas sont des cadres à
d'autres catégories bien qu'il soit
également intéressé que quand les
retraites ont été soumises à des
cotisations nouvelles de 1% sur le
régime général et de 2% sur les régimes
complémentaires
c'est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'avait premier monsieur giscard
d'estaing en 1974 alors voilà pour les
cadres on va parler tout le monde mais
les agriculteurs en tout cas ce qui à
oui ou non dans votre programme des
assises foncier cantonaux pour régler le
problème de l'utilisation et
d'affectation des terres mensonge quant
à l'explication de monsieur giscard
d'estaing réalité je propose en effet la
création d'offices ce foncier cantonaux
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce qu'ils
pensaient cantonaux de la bureaucratie
mais ce sont des offices fait uniquement
pour lutter contre la spéculation
foncière et les agriculteurs savent bien
de quoi je parle
de la même façon il est clair que ces
hausses espère que je l'écris parce que
je les dis on n'a pas le droit d'ignorer
ce que je dis est ce que j'écris pour
dire ensuite des inepties ou des
mensonges à la télévision ces offices
fond si cantonaux seront gérés par les
agriculteurs eux-mêmes
qu'est ce que vous voulez il faut
absolument comprendre aujourd'hui que le
sol terre c'est un outil de travail et
je veux que cet outil travail soit
protégé de telle sorte que les
agriculteurs et surtout les jeunes
puissent développer leurs activités dans
le cadre de l'exploitation familiale
agricole cent mille exploitations
familiales agricoles ont disparu au
cours de ces dernières années
est-ce qu'il faut donc ne rien faire
pour arrêter cette hémorragie en
dernière question la dissuasion elle est
d'importance puisque on se demande si au
fond vous êtes crédibles pour
éventuellement à tuer sur le bouton
atonie qui est une des fonctions du
président de la république puisque vous
êtes opposé à la force de frappe
non non non non il faut te encore un
mensonge supplémentaire et c'est quand
même très triste que dans un domaine
pareil tous les français devraient
s'associer pour la défense de la patrie
président de la république sortant se
permettent de dégager l'opinion publique
tout de même je n'ai pas dit cela
j'ajoute que avoir du sang-froid pour
appuyer sur le bouton de la guerre
atomique exige d'avoir autant de sang
froid pour ne pas appuyer sur le bouton
de la guerre mais qu'il faut examiner
ces deux problèmes l'un après l'autre je
veux dire qu'il faut avoir une très
grande maîtrise de soi même sur une arme
ce qui s'appelle disons la force
nucléaire la force atomique ou bien la
force de frappe
c'est la même chose qui en effet a
suscité il y a un temps de grâce
discussion les socialistes auraient
souhaité que l'on prenne une autre voie
mais comme ils ont considéré à partir
des années 1976 à 1977 que c'était
devenu la réalité notre âme et que notre
défense reposer uniquement sur la
stratégie de dissuasion alors comme
sommes des patriotes nous avons il faut
le faire et j'ai moi-même ici un texte
que je vais vous lire c'est une
déclaration que j'ai faite le 15 avril
80 l afp
je voulais lui parce qu'il faut que les
nos auditeurs et téléspectateurs que les
françaises et les français sachent où se
trouve la vérité je lis la stratégie de
dissuasion nucléaire nationale est la
seule qui puisse être actuellement de
nature éloigner les dangers de conflit
la défense de la france doit être
assurée et l'autonomie de notre décision
garantie il ne faut pas pour autant
négliger nos forces conventionnelles une
défense même fondé sur les matériel
perfectionné n'est rien si elle ne se
plie pas d'abord sur la résolution de la
nation tout entière précis nous n'avons
pas à voter les crédits militaires
cela ne signifie pas du tout que nous
repoussions cette force et cette
stratégie
cela veut dire quand on refuse d'écrire
qui envoie lui elle nous refaisons
également le budget de l'état parce que
nous considérons qu'il exprime une
mauvaise politique générale et nous ne
votons pas de budget de l'état cela veut
pas dire que nous ne voulions pas
financer l'ensemble des actions qui
concernent la vie de la france
mais nous ne voulons pas porter la
responsabilité d'une politique de
chômage d'échec et de déclin et même sur
le plan militaire
monsieur giscard d'estaing tromper
l'opinion publique récemment en
affirmant par exemple qu'il avait pris
l'initiative de lancer un sixième
sous-marin nucléaire
cela n'est pas exact ces décisions ont
été prises d'abord par monsieur pompidou
ensuite par monsieur poèmes et monsieur
giscard d'estaing peu de temps après
après avoir repris cette initiative
s'est empressé de la mettre sous le
boisseau en faisant perdre trois ans à
la construction de ces sous-marins
j'ai d'ailleurs dit en une autre
circonstance que deux sous marins
étaient nécessaires si l'on voulait nous
suivre la logique de cette forme
d'armement c'est à dire d'être en
disposition ou de soubey de la surface
des océans de représenter une menace
suffisante pour qu'aucun adversaire ne
songe à nous agresser
monsieur giscard d'estaing je n'hésite
pas à le dire
je mesure la gravité de mes propos a
menti une fois de plus mais cette fois
ci sur l'idée que nous nous faisons de
la naissance de la patrie à sigean le
point l'ensemble de vos réponses
cela vous fait pas dans la nuance si
vous prenez si vous prenez si vous
prenez l'ensemble de mes déclarations je
vais mois ferme ont des comptes et je
vais vous dire que monsieur giscard
d'estaing quand même réussi à dire 12
mensonge en 20 minutes
hier soir je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
son record mais s'il prend là et une
fâcheuse habitude alors que vous avez
failli tout ça dans le débat pourquoi
n'ai je pas dit tout cela dans le débat
parce que monsieur giscard d'estaing n'a
pas osé me poser la question songez que
nous avons été près de deux heures face
à face il y à 48 heures et que monsieur
giscard d'estaing ne m'a posé que deux
des questions dont nous venons par les
selles des nationalisations
s'inverserait listed race succession
c'est tout pas un autre de ces mêmes
hommes de ces problèmes un peu le
problème de la force de frappe et de
crédibilité remet pas de la même façon
voilà la réalité c'est à dire qu'il ya
sur les douze questions qui l'a traité
et dire soit on pourrait dire que neuf à
dix d'entre elles n'ont même pas été
évoqué alors que nous étions là pour
cela
c'est là que je trouve qu'ils ont
choquant pour la démocratie que l'un des
deux candidats le candidat sortant
président de la république encore pour
quelques jours n'ait pas eu le courage
face à face de me poser les questions
qui m'aurait permis de lui dire ce que
je vous dis ce soir et d'attendre le
lendemain pour déverser sur l'opinion
publique une série d'affirmations qui
incitent à la peur et qui sont de 1 mon
avis voyez-vous dans dans les campagnes
électorales c'est vrai que au niveau
d'un canton d'une municipalité on entend
dire des gens mal informés des
adversaires politiques un peu excité un
peu secteur s'adresser l'année se voit
terminer si vous permettez s'adressait
comme cela des imputations calomnieuses
mais le président de la république en
exercice qui s'adresse à un homme
candidats dont le chant élections sont
très grande pour dimanche prochain et
qui se permet de traiter ainsi par la
voie du banc
uj toute une politique qui est l'autre
politique qu'ils le choix des français
moi j'ai plus de respect pour mon
adversaire jamais gelé procéder de cette
façon et si vous me voyez maintenant ce
soir et si sévère à l'égard de ce
comportement
j'en appelle aux braves gens qu'ils
entendent ils sont donnés de chant
est-ce que cela n'est pas méritée que de
reprocher à monsieur giscard d'estaing
d'avoir menti à l'opinion publique
oui je voulais jouer simplement vous
dire qu'au fond on est en campagne
électorale est ce qu'on ne prenait pas
la mouche un peu importe ce qui est au
fond des arguments c'est la règle du jeu
non non non c'est pas du tout est en
règle du jeu je suis sûr vous du stade
si peu pour me piquer parce que je vais
j'espère d'ailleurs j'espère bien que ce
n'est pas comme ça que vous considérez
la démocratie bah vous pourrez chercher
à travers toute cette campagne à travers
les semaines qui sont de deux mois comme
ça acharné sur les dents ou on pourrait
toujours prononcé des paroles un peu
vive
s'il m'est arrivé comme cela disons de
ses dires à la polémique
jamais jusqu'à prétendre que le
programme de mon adversaire ou de mes
concurrents pouvaient comporter ce qui
ne comportait pas monsieur giscard
d'estaing jusqu alors s'était contenté
de biaiser ou de tromper les français
sur son programme maintenant ils tombent
sur le mien il est normal que je défende
ce ne sont pas de bonnes moeurs
électorales
je voudrais que la dignité prennent le
pas sur la compétition
c'est ça le respect de la démocratie et
je crois le reste est de la france vous
déplorez un peu les termes de la
compétition mais la réalité est là ce
qu'au fond votre programme ne fait pas
peur certains catégories de français
il pourrait faire peur si bien entendu
il prenait pour argent comptant ce que
leur dit monsieur giscard d'estaing
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il le dit au
fond monsieur giscard d'estaing il sait
bien que l'opinion publique que le
condamne pour une large part on sait
qu'il a échoué même ses partisans
tout le monde sait qu'il a échoué tout
le monde sait qu'il n'a pas su maîtriser
les grandes maladies du monde moderne
notamment dans un pays comme la france
pays qui plus que d'autres souffrent
aujourd'hui puisqu'on shady les
avant-hier soir qu'il était le 13e sur
15e parmi les grands pays industriels
qui souffre du chômage qui souffrent de
l'inflation qui souffrent le plus de
l'europe du marché commun des inégalités
sociales qui souffrent de l'exclusion de
sa jeunesse la jeunesse n'entre pas dans
notre société
donc c'est une cause
de de révolte et d'insécurité pour tout
le monde c'est de cela monsieur giscard
d'estaing le sait au fond tout cela est
fait pour que on oublie le véritable
problème le véritable débat le véritable
problème de cette campagne c'est de
savoir si on aura une autre politique
qui nous débarrassera de mes échecs qui
nous permettra de sortir de l'enfer du
fromage qui nous permettra d'aller vers
l'emploi vers la croissance et même
allons plus loin qui nous permettra de
retrouver de l'espoir par le le
changement une capacité créatrice
d'avoir envie quoi d'être la france
telle que peut être la france et pas
simplement ce pays que la politique
actuelle conduit peu à peu vers sa
décadence moi je crois dans la france et
je peux le dire monsieur giscard
d'estaing n'y croit pas vraiment car il
laisse les choses aller alors à la
dernière minute il sait bien que ça va
mal pour lui à la dernière minute et à
deux trois jours du scrutin du vote des
français
il n'a plus que ce moyen là un honnête
homme des délires et ce moyen je veux
dire le manceau à compter du moment où
la campagne électorale se situe sur ce
terrain là j'y vois de l'affolement dans
son cas mais je dois dire aux françaises
et aux français qui m'écoutent je dois
leur dire
réfléchissez la france est vraiment
autre chose qu'un pays frileux un pays
heureux on va quand même pas vous faire
le coup une fois de plus il faut qu'à
partir de lundi prochain ou se démettre
de votre destinée et de vos actions
et voilà pourquoi je crois nécessaire
aujourd'hui de parler sur le ton sévère
king autres questions d'actualité
monsieur chirac a pris hier position à
nouveau contre vous alors deux questions
ça vous a surpris est ce que ça vous
embarrassent j'écoutais ça ne pouvait
pas me surprendre dans la mesure où
monsieur chirac avait déjà indiqué que
pour sa part il
votre et pour monsieur giscard d'estaing
tout en ajoutant qu'il laissait
l'ensemble de ses électeurs qui
représente 18 % d'opinions publiques
libres de choisir leur âme et conscience
et je ne l'ait pas entendu entendu dire
le contraire c'est à dire je crois qu'il
a fait cela non je n'ai pas entendu dire
le contraire il s'est contenté il a
great et l'âme et la conscience de ses
électrices et de ses électeurs vers un
vote qui serait un vote de méfiance et
d'opposition à mon égard mais il n'a pas
du tout invité ses électrices et
électeurs à voter pour monsieur giscard
d'estaing il semble bien que ces mots-là
lui brûle les lèvres car il ne les
prononce jamais alors est ce qui les
invite à l'abstention je n'en sais rien
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il me désigne
comme l'adversaire mais il ne désigne
pas monsieur giscard d'estaing comme son
ami ou ceux d'alliés ça ne vous
intéresse pas nous sommes embarrasse pas
jeu mais comptez sur moi sur des
suffrages sur de monsieur chirac que je
pense ou plus exactement je suis jamais
monté sur monsieur chirac
quant à ses électrices et électeurs eux
je leur parle comme je parle aux autres
et je suis sûr que beaucoup plus
nombreux sont ceux qu'on ne le croit
généralement qui ont voté pour les
autres candidats et notamment pour
monsieur chirac et qui on aspire comme
moi au changement et qu'ils seraient
heureux de retrouver ou de rejoindre
comment dirais-je le grand mouvement
populaire le grand rassemblement
populaire que j'appelle moi même on se
sentirait tellement peu à l'aise non
seulement la gauche toute entière qui se
trouve déjà à mes côtés mais aussi
beaucoup de femmes beaucoup d'hommes qui
souffrent aussi autant que les autres
qui s'inquiète qui s'angoissent qui ont
préféré voter pour monsieur chirac
surtout sans doute dans les milieux des
classes moyennes les petites et moyennes
entreprises mais qui lorsqu'ils auront à
choisir entre leur responsable de la
situation présente de leur écrasement et
mois ci représente sans doute les
socialistes et la gauche je suis tel que
je suis je n'ai pas jamais trompé
personne sur ce que j'entends fait mais
moi quand même je suis pour l'avenir je
représente les forces de la jeunesse des
forces du travail et je crois que
beaucoup des lectrices et lecteurs de
monsieur chirac ont un vide
venir à nous je viens d'écouter votre
ton là surtout au début de notre
entretien j'ai l'impression voulu dire
si c'est un peu ce ton alors ce que ça
veut dire que la force tranquille que
proclament vos affiches c'est dur de la
tenir jusqu'à sa campagne
je suis indignée indigné et je ne crois
pas que la tranquillité d'esprit
m'interdise l'indignation
lorsque je vois de quelle façon on
traite les françaises et les français
d'abord on les a maltraité pendant sept
ans en réduisant le plus grand nombre
d'entre eux à vivre dans l'incertitude
et dans l' angoisse
ensuite on est très mal en les trompant
au moment où il s'agit pour eux de se
prononcer en toute clarté en jouant sur
des réflexes de peur en annonçant je ne
sais quel désordre lors que le désordre
et la wii cela m'indigne mais cela ne me
fait pas sortir de mes gonds simplement
j'entends parler avec clarté
j'ai dit avec sévérité nous ne sommes
pas dans une partie de dentelle et
autant j'étais décidé à rester comme je
l ai toujours été au cours de cette
campagne
celui qui explique pour convaincre
autant j'entends dire aujourd'hui ce
soir aux millions de français de
français qui m'écoutent que la
démocratie mérite d'être mieux respecter
et ne l'est aujourd'hui par le président
de la république sortant et j'imagine
s'il restait au pouvoir si par malheur
il reste au pouvoir
qu'est-ce qui se passerait s'il est
capable de mentir aux français comme il
vient de le faire à mon propos alors ne
mentiras t-il pas davantage à l'égard de
tous les autres si la recherche du
pouvoir
l'ambition du pouvoir doit conduire un
homme responsable a manqué à l'honnêteté
pure et simple alors notre démocratie
cours à de grands risques et c'est ce
que je veux faire comprendre
imaginez encore pendant sept ans tout ce
que nous venons de vivre pendant les
sept années précédentes
je crois que la sagesse consiste à
mettre un terme à une expérience qui n'a
que trop duré monsieur giscard d'estaing
le sait il perd son sang froid
je lui demande quand même puisqu'il
reste le temps de réfléchir avant
dimanche prochain de faire avec moi ce
qui doit être fait de bien vouloir
m'entendre bref d'être digne et de ne
compter que sur la vérité pour retenir
raison
et